e
okay it's 10: a.m. it's actually 10:01
so we're not starting another GE off
right we're a minute behind uh going to
open the orientation for the house
election law committee we'll start with
the pledge um representative uh toner
you want to start with the you want to
pledge okay welcome welcome it's good to
be back um welcome to the house election
law committee we're going to do a a
quick 20 minute
orientation um so the first thing we'll
do is Let's uh do the old go around the
horn and have all the members introduce
themselves quite quickly we've got 20
minutes so I get I'll I'll give my uh
speech on speed here at the end of this
but uh we're going to move quickly on
everything so representative gusowski
would you like to introduce yourself
where you're
from please hit the mic button
yep uh my name's Jim galovski from
Northwood represent Northwood and
Nottingham and it is my first go round
just newly elected excellent next
up I'm Travis toner I represent Belmont
and I'm also newly elected
excellent I'm representative Alvin C and
I'm uh this is my second term but I was
on Transportation committee last
time hi I'm representative Heath Howard
I represent the towns of straford and
barington I'm uh subbing today uh I
normally serve on uh Edna
thanks hello I'm I'm Katherine pom
O'Brien I'm from Derry this is my fifth
term in the house I was previously in
the labor committee and this is my
fourth term on this
committee hi thanks I'm Juliet Harvey
bullia and I represent Tilton and samton
this is my third term and I was uh
serving on resources Recreation
development last ter time around thanks
representative Clayton wood represent fi
and Chai Chester and this is my second
term and second term on Election
law I'm Jerry Ward from Portsmith I
think I've been on this six times too
long
anyway good morning my name is Lisa
merer I represent the towns of gtown and
where uh this is my second term I am
substituting for representative qua
today and I usually um present on the
hhsa committee in my second term thank
you and I'm Ross be i al represent gown
and wear now um proud to be back in my
old District of 44 before it turned to
39 and now I'm back to 44 I guess um but
gwn hello I'm representative Claudine
Burnham and I'm from um straford
District 2 Milton and Rochester Ward
five this is my second on Election
law I'm Connie Lane and this is my
fourth term on Election law my fourth
term as a representative and I'm from uh
ward two here in
conquer hi I'm Bob worry um I'm from
Hillsboro District 13 which is the town
of
Hudson and this is my second term and my
law representative Matt Wilhelm
represent at Manchester Ward one uh
fourth term in the house uh previously
served as the House minority leader and
this is my first term on Election law
although I did have the honor of serving
with the chairman and Connie and others
uh on redistricting a few years ago
we'll show you how to do it right we'll
get you looking forward to it thank you
chairman James Nome uh representing
Hopkinton and Bo and this is my first
term in the
house uh Gary Gilmore do would three
this is my sixth term but it is my there
been a 22-year absence in between so
this is sort of like a newbie too and
this is my probably my fourth term on
Election
law welcome back okay um so we'll do
some quick housekeeping measures here um
so we have in our possession 70 bills we
might get to 80 um so that's more than
double the next Comm
um so for everyone who decided we
shouldn't have a table calendar you when
we're sitting through the 120th hour of
hearings you'll maybe think about that
but uh so because we're going to have 75
or 80 bills all said and done um we're
going everything we do is going to have
to be quick um
so I will do my best when scheduling to
figure out which bills have more public
interest than not um but I am not a
psychic um so things that I do is I look
at like online signups and that sort
sort of deal to kind of gather it but
because I have to do it a week out and a
lot of bills don't get pushed online for
Testimony it's a little bit of a
guessing game so I'll be relying on
experience um with topics we've handled
before and um obviously any sort of data
point that I can get but there will more
likely than not if there's significant
public testimony be time limits for
Testimony because otherwise we will be
here um we we actually just won't won't
make early Bill deadlines we just won't
do it so uh you can go ahead and block
off Tuesdays will be the days we
primarily meet um those days will be
mostly full days today is the exception
um because my wife has an ultrasound for
our new child so uh you guys got you
guys get to get off early because I get
to go and be a dad um but um other than
that that's kind of going to be the
Cadence uh I have told uh the ranking
member representative Lane I won't be
calling um any bills that's not noticed
without her consent it's not the rule
but we're going to do that um I think
it's a good practice of precedent so um
we will doing that um bills will be
noticed so you'll see in every time
there's a hearing the default will be
executive session may be called uh I do
reserve the right to open the bill up
for discussion so if we have some
downtime which I don't think we'll have
much of uh I'm going to put that in
there so we can talk to each other and
sort things out in public um but you
don't have to worry about the vote
actually taking place uh unless it is
specifically noticed like it is this
afternoon
um so I think that's um that's my big
speed trying to think if there's
anything else that I'm missing oh I need
to introduce our um committee assistant
Robin are you here or did she leave she
left all right so uh we have our uh
committee assistant Robin and our um oh
I'm not connected to the internet that's
worthless um I believe our researcher is
named David I'll send it around um but
um both our committee assistant and our
committee researcher are new um so if
you have anything um that you need
researched um obviously that goes
through the chair um but please you know
send it to me and um I I will say our
committee assistant's been wonderful so
far I haven't had a chance really to
interact with our committee researcher
too much but um if you need anything
she's wonderful I'm H here to help um
trying to think what else uh you'll you
should have they're they're working on
PR all of the bills but obviously we
don't have them all yet so they can't
print things they don't have um but when
that comes you can expect a uh a stack
about that
thick um I think that's it does anybody
have any questions comments concerns
before we have the secretary of state do
some
introductions perfect uh secretary Mr
secretary it's good to see
you thank you Mr chairman it's good to
see you as well members of the committee
it's great to see the veterans back in
the room and it's nice to meet the new
ones we look forward to working with you
um just before we get into the
orientation um a couple of resources
that are available to you um
representative Harvey bolia could you
just raise your your election law
book um we've passed those out to the
newer members uh if the older members
need one of those just stop in the
office in room 204 the state house and
we'll be happy to get one of those for
you we will be publishing
the next updates uh this summer after
the legislative session is over so that
for the next uh legislative session
you'll have a completely updated book
there is an addendum that is available
that have all of the laws that passed
during the last legislative session and
we will make sure that you get copies of
those so that you have the up-to-date uh
inserts for the book The Other larger
document is the election procedure
manual uh which we distribute to all
local election officials who have
responsibilities in conducting an
election uh that's considered the Bible
of running
elections and you should have a copy of
that as well if you don't uh just come
and see us
um our office door by the way this is
Aon Hennessy who you'll probably be
seeing more than me uh during the
session Aon is my deputy secretary of
state and uh you know we have a great
working relationship and so so I'm sure
you'll see a lot of both of us uh over
the course of the
session the Secretary of State's office
is a fairly large state agency and the
among the divisions that we have are
corporations where we register all
business entities that operate in New
Hampshire uh we have the Bureau of
Securities which regulates um broker
dealers that deal with financial
instruments we have the division of
Vital Records which keeps track of
births deaths marriages uh divorces
things like that and we have the
division of archives and Records
management which uh keeps the state's
most historic uh
documents um everything that goes back
to pre-colonial times I think the oldest
document we have in the in the archives
is the mid 1600s and then a lot of
Records uh through the colonial times
some great civil war records uh uh
Governor records everything in between
uh and then we manage uh agency records
that are uh between active status and
destruction status there's a retention
period that we keep track of if agencies
need to retrieve records that are in the
archives uh we can uh do that for them
uh we've got over 100,000 boxes of
agency records in the state archives and
we uh you know there's constant uh new
records being brought to the archives
and a destruction process that goes
along with that but one of the most
important functions that we do uh in the
Secretary of State's office is elections
and that's why we're here in front of
you this
morning
um we have been very busy the last
couple of
years um and the things that we've
accomplished are a brand new
registration database which replaced the
Legacy system that we had uh that's
going to be really beneficial to the
local election officials that really are
responsible for maintaining the data
that gets entered uh into the
system uh along with that we have in
place some really strong cyber security
measures to make sure that our
electronic systems are safe and secure
um and at some point in the future we
can talk about uh you know those those
processes and
procedures um the B ballot law
commission has approved two new ballot
counting
devices um that are replacing the Legacy
um acote system which has been used now
for 30 plus years in cities and towns in
New
Hampshire the newer devices use digital
scan technology which means that an
image of every single ballot can be
recorded and and the advantage to that
is it really opens up the doors to the
types of postelection audits that we can
conduct uh you know comparing the
electronic record to the actual physical
record of the actual paper ballot that
was cast in the
election um of the two devices that have
been approved one has um received EAC
election assistance um approvals the EAC
is a federal agency that sets standards
for those
devices um and so there are uh several
dozen Towns now that are you actually
using the voting Works device which
utilizes open source software and we can
talk about what that means in a future
election uh again significant
improvements the other device is the
Dominion uh image cast device which is
sold and maintained by LHS uh Associates
the same company that Services the ACU
vote machines that are out there um
their device is not being deployed yet
there're still waiting for some final
approvals uh in addition uh there is a
large number there are a large number of
towns now that are using electronic Pole
books as the check-in uh vehicle they
have to be maintained in parallel with a
paper checklist but the advantage that
the cities and towns are seeing uh are
uh uh efficiency when voters are
checking in because they can get into
any line to check in and not one that is
assigned by letters of the alphabet and
then at the end of the night when they
close out the electronic poll books the
number of Voters that actually checked
in for that election is instant and it
saves the supervisors of the checklist
the time of having to go through every
page on paper counting those uh those
numbers and then because the information
that is collected is in electronic form
that information can be uploaded to the
voter registration data base uh and
hopefully there will be a lot fewer
errors as a result of that process
because um the supervisors of the
checklist don't have to manually enter
that data that they're reading off of uh
a a checklist
form in addition to all of those items
um we have
uh and we've mentioned this to the
committee before but we have more funds
in The Help America vote act uh election
fund account that we need to actually
run that program and so we have been
cost sharing with cities and towns for
the purchase of new ballot counting
devices and electronic Pole books their
choice um and there are many towns that
have taken us up on that offer and we
are spending down some of the Sur plus
of the funds that we have in that
regard uh there's just uh two or three
minutes left uh before your next hearing
so uh I'm going to stop there and just
say that uh you know we're we have an
open door policy in my office if you
have any questions or want to talk about
bills or whatever come on over I would
like to encourage groups of you to uh
schedule a meeting with us at The
Archives so that we can give you a tour
of the we call it the Hava office but
that's where the staff maintains the
help America vote act uh mandates
maintaining the voter uh registration
database it's where we train election
officials on those systems uh and
there's a lot that goes on up there that
uh we would certainly love to show you
so with that Mr chair I'm happy to
answer some questions if you think
there's
time we have three minutes to kill so if
anybody has questions three minutes we
have three minutes to
kill okay uh not seeing any thank you m
do you want to introduce your do did you
introduce your staff I'm sorry I know I
know we um deputy secretary Hennessy um
is there anyone else that we should in
our orbit we should be aware of not here
today but um uh Patty Lovejoy is the
senior deputy secretary you may see
heard at some of the hearings elections
director is Patricia
petsu um communications director is uh
Anna
spentech uh we have a voter uh and
Civics Outreach coordinator uh that's
Lily woo and I'm sure at some point over
the course of the legislative session
you'll get to meet all of those
individuals okay all right thank you
representative
Lane you reminded me about Miss Bloom
has she started um going to schools and
doing and what what is she done I think
she was hard this summer right has she
been active since then doing and what
are her duties exactly she she's been
very active there was a great uh article
in the conquered monitor uh is either
this morning or over the weekend uh she
spent the first few months um learning
uh one of the charges that I gave to her
was uh to go out and talk with the
different constituencies of Elections to
find out what the needs are she has done
a great job identifying those and is
ready to roll out some really great
programs the scope is well beyond just
schools um my instruction to her was um
to educate um not only students but also
groups like veterans uh minorities
seniors uh with the goal being to
encourage more people regarding
regardless of age to participate in the
election process as poll workers so that
we can replenish our ranks um that's a
really tall order but uh there's some
exciting things that are going to come
out of this and um you it's it's great
to have her on board awesome thank you
okay uh thank you yes representative
willhelm just a quick question for the
secretary sure got a moment did you have
the current balance of Hava
funds um
I I don't have the exact number but uh
it's in it's probably in the $12 million
range say it's about 12 million from my
last count all right thank you um thank
you Mr secretary it's uh 1020 so we're
going to end up our orientation nailed
it um and open up the public hearing uh
for House Bill 67 FNA relative to
agreements with the Secretary of State
for the use of accessible voting
machines uh before we start the hearing
I want to give a quick shout out uh we
have we have a uh special guest in our
audience uh former representative Hamlet
has joined us she couldn't get away I
guess so it's good to see you even
though you're not um with us anymore and
you are missed um
honorable uh honorable Hamlet um what oh
Russ is here here but he's he's on
everybody knows who Russ is mean needs
no introduction you weren't here to
introduce yourself it's a joy to see you
again I I I'm sure you feel that way um
okay uh first up representative weary
and representative we you've already
made the first faux PA of the year I
need a pink card from you ah uh after
you're done introducing House Bill 67 uh
so we've got about
one sorry counting oopsies uh yeah one
two three four five six seven eight uh
people if you need to sign up please
fill out a pink card hand it to
representative gasovi who will then uh
run it on up for us um uh everybody has
signed up for two minutes so I'm gonna
ask people to keep their remarks the two
minutes um the next bill I don't think
has a lot of people signed up so if we
go over not the end of the world um but
when we get to two minutes I might say
hey we're we're getting to you know if
you could reach the end but I won't be
cutting off hard at two minutes but if
we could please keep our remarks uh
abbreviated to the time you requested
which everybody requested two minutes uh
and then I will be imposing the rule
that I had uh last term which is
lobbyist go last so if you're a Lobby
you can plan to go last uh thank you
representative Wy all right thank you Mr
chair and honorable committee members
for the record my name is Robert Wy I
have the privilege of representing
Hillsboro District 13 the great town of
Hudson the fifth largest town by
population in New Hampshire on a quick
relevant personal note for 10 years my
wife was a rehabilitation teacher at the
Perkins School for the Blind in
Watertown Massachusetts and the concern
that this proposed legislation addresses
is on accessible voting systems is near
and dear to my heart um to be up front
this is really the uh initiation of my
colleague uh representative Pig and uh
he's just allowed me the honor to speak
before this committee to set the context
for House Bill 67 allow me to briefly
review the Bill's predecessor from last
year House Bill
1264 in 2024 that bill was signed into
law by former governor sonunu on July
3rd prior to this law accessible voting
systems were in place only for State
elections with the federal office on the
ballot these systems were not made
available at polling locations for local
elections as a result except for a
couple of the communities that have
their own accessible voting systems
individuals with disabilities were not
universally afforded equal opportunities
to vote to vote privately and
independently in local elections this
lack of provision is in fact a violation
of the American with Disabilities Act
and its implementing
regulations last year election law heard
compelling testimony from the public as
to some of the hor speci ific
discriminatory voting experiences
endured by those voters who did not have
these systems available in fact some New
Hampshire communities have been sued for
their failure to suitably provide
accessible voting systems during
election so the current law that was
enacted in July of 2024 now requires
that each polling place have at least
one accessible voting system for use in
local elections through a pilot program
with the Secretary of State's office the
secretary's office must share the
machines it has has with cities and
towns for the s first 6 months of 2025
during town meeting sessions this will
allow municipalities to use the state's
machines during a year when there are no
other Statewide
elections this pilot program was a
result of several Cooperative
discussions with the Secretary of
State's office as well as with input
from both the disability rights Center
of New Hampshire and the New Hampshire
Municipal Association now that that
context has been laid out we come to the
bill before you
hb67 my honorable colleague from exitor
represented Mark page and I are
privileged to introduce this bipartisan
bill this bill simply seeks to remove
the pilot program or to move the pilot
program into a permanent agreement
beginning in July of 2025 and it makes
the necessary funding Provisions for the
purchase of additional systems uh uh
that might be necessary to enable an
ongoing program on behalf of the May
stakehold holders behind this effort I
kindly ask asked for this Este steam
committee to support this Bill thank you
for your time and I'll be glad to try
and answer any questions you may have
other questions from the
committee seeing none thank you
representative weary and you'll get me
your card um secretary scan I have a
card from you is that for this bill um
okay I'm GNA without objection you
didn't write the bill number down I'm
going to write the bill number down on
here all right I don't want to I don't
want to get caught forging records from
thank you Mr chairman members of the
committee I'm David scanland Secretary
of State uh here to provide some
information on this bill um as rib of
wary mentioned uh the legislature
required us to enter into a pilot
program uh to make accessible voting
equipment available to uh cities and
towns for the upcoming March and
subsequent uh uh Town meetings and we
have done that on our end we're making
the hardware that's necessarily
available to the uh cities to the towns
I don't believe there's any City
elections except for maybe one
um and and we have a vendor that is able
to program the devices for each
individual local
election um so from the state standpoint
we are ready what I can tell you though
that this this uh process has been on
The Fast trck and we have quite a few
towns uh that are expressing
reservations um uh about uh the speed of
this and the cost because there is a
cost involved with the programming of
these elections and depending on the
type of election the programming could
be significantly higher than others for
example Senate Bill 2 towns have to put
uh all of their warrant articles on the
official ballot and so all of that
language has to be programmed into the
used that's a concern and I know there's
some representatives from the towns here
so you know you may hear more about that
uh in a
moment moving forward however
um there are we are aware that there are
a number of physical accessible voting
equipment devices
uh that are available out there that may
also work well with State elections so
that we could have one device uh in
every polling place the device would
remain in the town and they would be
used for every election and we have been
going through the process of vetting
those systems we've included the
disabilities Community as a part of that
process um at some point we'll be
putting out a request for proposals on
that um all of that does take some time
um and whatever the device is we want to
have complete buyin with the
disabilities Community uh but we also
want to have Buy in with the cities and
towns when that happens so that the
point that I'm coming to is that I think
the track that we're on is a little too
ambitious and I would like to slow uh
the process down just a little bit so
that we make good decisions in this
process and not
uh
um you know make a choice that we regret
later because we're trying to do this
too fast I don't think we're talking
about a lot of time uh months rather
than years but but I think that we need
to um you know really make sure that we
take measured steps in this process to
make sure that what we do is right uh
for everybody that's involved in this
process and Aon do you want to add
anything to that
um thank you Aon Hennessy deputy
secretary of state
so I think um the bill has a um
implementation date of or enacted date
of this summer and if we were to move to
January 1st of 2026 I think we could
better meet the requirements of the
legislation and I'll save all of my
fiscal note um comments for um the
finance
questions question I was writing down
those notes uh representative Lane um
thank you Mr chair
um Miss Hennessy sorry I have a cold and
um I'm having a hard time talking um if
we move out the
date the pilot program ends this summer
so there will be a six-month
Gap what would you propose for that
thank you for the question for those uh
cities that do not have their own
devices currently I believe our office
could work with them depending on what
device I mean there is a chance that we
would have new devices by that time um
but for those that don't have them and
if we don't have them by that time we
could work with them if they would like
to use our devices so similar to what's
going on right
now follow
the reason I ask is because cities will
be voting in November and they may want
to implement it in November which comes
in that Gap period so okay Mr chair if I
could just qu um just give a little
extra information on that so our devices
right now are kind of complicated and
almost 10 years old so the reason why
the language of this bill would not work
for um our current devices is because of
they're a bit outdated and local
election officials would have a very
difficult time um resetting them up and
doing the um programming piece of things
um other than programming for a specific
election but the the piece that our it
department has to go through to set it
up for a new election each
time other questions from the committee
yeah one more there it
is
sorry thank you for taking my question I
was just wondering you you mentioned the
the the cost what what what is the cost
the range some towns from the low end to
the high end just to put in perspective
thank you representative for the
question so if you have one election and
you have a small ballot size it's $600
to program it um if you have multiple
elections for example I heard from a
small town this morning they have a town
ballot and then two separate School
ballots um I believe their Town ballot
is small so perhaps um it's still be
$600 but for them to have three
$1,800 further questions from the
committee see none thank you thank you
okay uh next up we're going to go into
members of the general public reminder
if you'd like to speak on this bill
please fill out a paint card before we
reach the end uh next up is going to be
law yeah press the button there you go
yes good morning and thank you Mr
chairman and their committee uh my name
is Fred forer and I
um I thank I want to thank you for the
opportunity to speak to you today and
report of the accessible voting
2017 um I worked a full
career had two wonderful
children had
grandchildren and my life was on track
and I was coasting to
retirement uh until the unexpected
happened and I became legally blind
when I had to give up my driving
abilities turning my my license and um
learn a new way of coping with
day-to-day life and during that process
I met some amazing people who are
already in the blind
Community um who helped me to see that
life didn't end when you became blind
and that
technology was our friend
um and the accessible voting systems is
a result of today's
technology and I've living in exiter
I've had the opportunity to use the
accessible voting systems for um local
elections and federal elections and it
has helped me immensely to um navigate a
a ballot just like the cited people do
so it's it's been a huge benefit for me
and
um I want to ask for your support in in
helping this to move forward and knowing
that technology is our friend um I know
that this is going to get even better
the further it goes down the
road so um thank you for your time and
um if you have any questions or comments
I'd be I'd try my best to respond to
that questions from the committee
representative
wood thank you m chairman thank you for
your question uh sounds to me that
you're an expert uh on using this can
you describe quickly what your
experience is and do you need any help
at all uh during the voting process yes
thank you for the question
um voting
um person come comes in and and enters
the code to start the process but once
that's entered I can navigate the the
system and navigate the ballots just as
a sighted person would stepping through
each race or office um just like a
regular a regular ballot um and choose
the per the candidates that are running
for the
office just by hitting the carriage
return on the keyboard um and then and
progressing all the way through to the
bottom of the ballot where at that point
I can review my selections to make sure
they're what I
chose and if they are I can choose to
print the ballot which is printed right
next to me and I then I would take it to
the counting machine and deposit it just
like any other voter
would thank you further questions from
the Committee hearing none thank you um
next up is going to
you good morning Mr committee chair and
committee members thank you so very much
for taking the time to listen to our
testimonies my name is Dana Trahan I am
also from exitor um a resident there I'm
also a part of the Coalition of blind
vision shed voters here in New Hampshire
and we've been working quite some time
with the Secretary of State's office and
with our local election workers as far
as accessible voting not only for state
and federal elections but now for Town
elections um I'm so very thankful for
the passing last year of HB
1264 it's uh very exciting to know that
there is going to be accessible voting
in Municipal elections for everyone
throughout the state it's great that
we're joining the vast majority of
states that that already have that in
place um hoping so very much that this
bill is able to pass as well so that
things continue to progress in a
positive motion um we're very excited to
have it be that you know in in March
that many of us are going to be able to
do so in town elections but it's also um
going to take a little time for the
general public you know whether they're
blind or vision impaired or fully cited
to learn that this is even an option at
the polling places so um I think in time
numbers will will progress and so
hopefully it won't be a a reflection if
thousands of us aren't voting on you
know at the beginning of March because
it's a matter of people learning that
the system exists and how it works
there's training videos out there and
and different things but the the more
the word can spread and maybe you can
all share with your constituents a
little bit um as well so um it's really
so important for us to be able to vote
privately and independently before so I
needed to either have somebody read the
ballot to me and Mark my ballot for me
um a little bit more with the system
itself that um Fred was sharing with you
you can either listen to it through
headphones and then make your selections
on the keyboard and for people that have
some Vision they can even vote with
using the tablet by enlarging the size
of the font on the tablet and just
tapping um so it's a great tool for
someone with a vision impairment but
also somebody that might have a hard
time filling in those over whether it be
arthritis or or problems with
dexterity um I did include a written
testimony that might say a little bit
more than than what I'm nervously saying
now um but I am again so very glad for
the passing of 1264 it's so important
for all of us in New Hampshire to have
the right to or the ability to vote
privately and independently um and I
look forward to you know hopefully
extending the pilot program so there
there won't need to be a time where
people some people get to try it but not
everybody gets to try it and is it
available or isn't it available you know
so hopefully things will run smoothly
and if you have any questions or
anything I can anything more I can share
please let me know excellent um any
questions from the
committee okay thank you so much thank
it's to your
left
yeah uh okay excellent um my name is
Andrew Harmon I'm a resident of new
Hampton New Hampshire um I want to start
by thanking the committee for all their
hard work with passing toll 64 last year
um as someone who works as an
accessibility tester I understand the
amount of work that must have gone into
this and the concerns that may be about
expanding the program but I would also
say that
the um that that is what the pilot
program is for and that extending it out
will give us the chance to address any
small quirks that might come up um
because as the system currently exists
it it works really really easily as
you've heard from other people um for
being able to complete a ballot um I
also wanted to um say that for the
warrant article side having lived in a
town that does tend to have one that is
both small and tends to have a lot of
Warrant articles being able to use the
one for-all system really excites me
because it will greatly reduce the
amount of time that I have to spend
moving through the warrant article
um uh especially privately since we are
such a small town and have such a small
voting place um so I I have other
testimony that I have with me and will
be happy to pass along when I'm done um
that may address that other side of it a
little bit better uh than I am also
nervously saying um and I am happy to
take any questions or comments uh thank
you um and thank you for bringing up
written testimony um huge pet peeve of
mine um and I I appreciate the um the me
uh the member of the public if you have
written testimony please do not
distribute it while you're speaking it's
a huge pet peeve of mind when members
are trying to like handle paperwork they
should be focused on you um so thank you
for holding on to that we will
definitely take that um but just for
everybody else he did the right thing um
and that's what I would like is uh we
want we want to focus on you so don't
introduce distractions for the members
and thank you for not doing that even
though you didn't know you did the right
thing um all right so we will take that
and um do you have any questions from
the
committee okay hearing none thank you
thank you very much thank you uh next up
is Jean Shiner oh um where do I hand
this to uh representative Lane will come
good
morning there you go is that better
that's much better thank you good
morning Mr chairman and members of the
election law committee my name is Jean
Shiner and I'm a resident of exitor
another one of
them I'm a member of the Coalition of
blind and vision impaired voters first I
want to thank you for passing HB 1264
last year this pilot project will help
Granite Staters with disabilities to
vote with the for the first time during
their Municipal elections and this is
very exciting and it's a big
milestone I want to take a step back and
give you a little information of my
background and tell you about the
Coalition of blind en vision impaired
voters long hard work on voting
accessibility I am told blind voting
with a secret ballot has been a passion
of mine for several
decades the Coalition is a Statewide
group of consumers and agency
Representatives working on voting access
for the past nine years we began working
with the Secretary of State's office
with the goal of filling out a ballot
placing it in the Box along with the
general Public's ballots at first we
could fill out the ballot using the one
for all but the ballot had to be placed
in a separate box and counted separately
in 2018 I was able to fill out my ballot
for the first time using one for all
placing it in the Box along with
everyone else's it was a feeling of
great
accomplishment along with working on
having state and federal elections
accessible regarding voting the
Coalition also wanted
towns and cities to have the same right
up until the passing of hb1
1264 conquered and exiter were the only
two places with accessible ballots for
City and town elections in conquered a
complaint was registered with the
Department of Justice and the City of
conquer has to provide accessibility for
their elections many of the vision
impaired community in exor have worked
on advocating for accessible voting for
several years and in March of 2023
exor's Town ballots were accessible it
is fantastic that other blind and low
vision voters Statewide can take
advantage of this opportunity for this
year on a more personal note the general
non-disabled public can walk into a
booth without thought and vote if there
is no accessible voting system available
I cannot vote with a secret ballot
before 2023 during Town elections I had
to ask someone to read and fill out the
ballot and it was usually Our Town Clerk
and those we had three ballots in exer
for our town meetings so it was a lot of
reading for her someone knew how I was
Voting I don't have any Vision I don't
have the option of using a magnifier if
the ballot is not accessible using the
tablet enables me to have my
constitutional right to a private secret
ballot it's a great
feeling words cannot
express the empowerment I feel when I
can vote and
place my ballot into the box just like
other non-disabled voters so there's
more work to be done we need to make
voting with an accessible ballot a
permanent right
a permanent thing I ask you to pass this
bill
hb67 I want everyone including blind
voters in the state to have this
right Thank you very much thank you will
we be taking questions from the
committee yes I can are there questions
from the
Committee hearing none thank you so much
thank you next up is Randy Pierce from
sorry there's a chair here for
tapping there we
go and there's a button I'm G to find or
you've already done that for me haven't
you the button is on uh the microphone
is situated is pointed to your to your
left so you'll need to reach to your
left and grab it and turn it there you
go okay you know simple accessibility
that button right and imagine if you
didn't have the accessibility of that
button you wouldn't be able to hear
people giving testimony it's pretty
dramatic and similarly you don't get to
hear the voice of many disabled voters
well beyond just the Blind and Visually
Impaired print disabilities of all types
are also included and just in the blind
Community there are 28,000 people here
in New Hampshire who could utilize that
system now part of the reason I want to
speak to that is with full appreciation
for how much tremendous progress we've
made thanks to your choice last year to
make House Bill 1264 law
now we're talking about are we going to
extend it and one of the biggest
challenges at future in sight we serve
all of the population of New Hampshire
one of the biggest challenges we hear is
they don't know what to expect when they
go to vote sometimes the machine's there
sometimes it's not and when you don't
know if it's going to be there you're
intimidated to use it and we don't want
to make intimidation around voting it's
too important a right now I appreciate
and respect the reasons why there's some
discussion from the secretary and deput
deputy secretary to delay and those
reasons may be sufficient but let's talk
about what that means we say we're going
to have a similar plan to the pilot to
get there I love that striving and
they've demonstrated they are willing to
and trying to but what has happened is
that it's been federal law that this
should be accessible and it hasn't
happened so if we delay this two things
are going to happen one would probably
going to have a lot of Municipal
elections without that system in place
and here's the second more powerful
after getting everybody's hopes up in
the community from now on every time
it's going to be there what we're going
to do is pull the rug right out from
under them and it won't be there for
some people and the intent may be there
but if it's not there then people are
going to say nothing's changed and
they're still not going to develop the
consistency and you're not going to get
their votes and I can tell you that the
blind population we serve and the
majority of them vast majority 80% are
new to their visual impairment because
it's happening later in life and the
reality is for them they're already
uncertain they're already lacking the
confidence and you're going to take away
the confidence from them because you're
not going to give them an access to it
unless you choose to say we're going to
find a way to pass it now is it fast
yeah will it require extra work yes but
the delay means just like if I don't
push the button for this microphone
you're not going to hear the voters in
your town in the way that you deserve
and more importantly the way they
deserve I'm happy to take any questions
obviously I'm passionate as a consumer
myself and as a person charged with help
helping to serve the 28,000 people in
New Hampshire who are blind and visually
impaired and thank you thank you for
testimony and it was great testimony um
my first question I need you to say who
you are and where you live sure I'm very
sorry for that I'm Randy Pierce I
currently live in Canterbury New
Hampshire though born in nashille grew
up in cook I got the state surrounded no
worries thank you for that all right now
now uh are there questions from the
committee all right uh seeing none thank
you so much and like it was great
testimony I didn't want to stop you like
you You Came Out Swinging and I loved it
I didn't want I didn't want to I didn't
want to hit you with with the roll so um
thank you all right next up is uh Kaylee
oh it's you're going be the the first
first last name I butcher this year I I
promise you it won't be the last last
name that I butcher um arraf
Sho wasn't even close I appreciate it
though you do it one more time for me
because I imagine you'll be back um
estadio estadio yeah pretty fonetic okay
um thank you chairman and members of the
House election law committee my name is
Kay stadio I'm a Durham voter and public
policy fellow with open democracy we're
a nonpartisan nonprofit representing
3600 voters across the state of New
Hampshire I'm submitting testimony today
to support
hb67 New Hampshire places extraordinary
value on community and voting and we
have to strive to make sure that town
meetings are inclusive of all
populations as well as we have heard
earlier today from the Secretary of
State their office has already issued a
request for proposal to replace the
existing accessible voting systems and
now is the time to ensure that they are
available for local elections conquer
has already been sued for not having an
accessible voting voting system during
their local elections and continuing not
to provide these essential devices
leaves the entire State wide open to a
similarly embarrassing lawsuit
implementing one forall voting systems
into local and town elections would also
be a wise preemptive move the language
demographics of several cities like NASA
and Manchester are quickly approaching
the voting rates act threshold of 10,000
citizens with limited English
proficiency which will mandate
jurisdictions to provide ballots in that
language incorporating language access
to accessible voting systems would
greatly ease this transition please vote
a to pass on hb67 and support Equitable
voting access for all New Hampshire
citizens and I also have written
testimony from staff member Autumn who
could not be here today and will you be
taking questions from the committee uh
yes if there are are there questions
from the committee seeing none thank you
if you could hand your testimony to
representative gusov he'll he'll ship it
Dar thank you Mr chair and the committee
on Joan dargy uh town clerk in Milford
also the president of the New Hampshire
City and town clerks
Association and a member of the
legislative committee um we what New
Hampshire City and town clerks are in
support of this bill um but we would I
would also like to Echo what the um
Secretary of State mentioned and that it
is on a very um quick time frame to turn
it around and I I believe in extension
would be would be helpful I've received
calls from um clerks from the smaller
town sounds that uh $6 to $1,800 per
election potentially is more than their
entire election
cost um with that said there we had a
demonstration at the Secretary of
State's um office on three different
machines and that was the Democracy live
image cast and voting works if the
language of this bill could somehow be
changed to give the city and towns um
more
um to allow them to make the decision
give them more of a decision in this um
because we saw where if one town has the
image cast machine they could
potentially use the accessible voting
image cast machine or the voting works
and um in using the same machine that
they're already using for the elections
the programming is less expensive but we
haven't had much time to really
investigate that whether it's good for
every everybody to have the same one
with the high cost of programming or
potentially use the the machines and get
their own accessible um voting equipment
I mean as far as um for for this spring
the bulk of the city and towns will be
doing um the pilot with the Secretary of
State's office so bulk of cities and
towns are going to be able to use this
um the Secretary of State mentioned that
for or November they would work with the
cities who have November elections or
anybody that has an election after March
to potentially continue the pilot so I I
believe that the Secretary of State
having that little more time to make a
better decision on this and figure out
how it's best going to work would would
be the best
thing okay will you be taking questions
from the committee yes I thought I saw
was
Lane thank you Mr chair and thank thank
you for being here miss Dary um my
question is when these smaller towns or
other cities or whatever um are they
aware that this is federal law and that
the reason that exiter and Conquer have
the had this was they were threatened
with a lawsuit yes and and they are
aware they the most comment that I got
was that they don't have anybody that
uses the current accessible voting
system so
so to get them in a position to spend
$1,800 where someone may not access it I
guess that that's where you're putting
it on the city and town potentially make
it their
decision I mean most mostly everybody is
in FA I mean everybody is in support of
it it's just looking at those smaller
towns and and I think having the
extended time to look at it may help
figure out a less expensive way for them
to do it
F questions from the Committee hearing
none thank you thank you um last up is
Sarah Burke Cohen from New Hampshire
Miss
Association morning excuse me good
morning there is a voice in here
someplace my name is Sarah burkeen and I
am a legislative advocate for the New
Hampshire Municipal Association as many
of you know the New Hampshire Municipal
Association is a member organization
made up of all the municipalities in the
state of New Hampshire I'm here to today
to testify in support of
hb67 you've heard testimony of the
importance and necessity for accessible
voting in the in a manner that allows an
individual with a disability to have
equal access to voting I will not
reiterate the test testimony but NH nhma
Echoes the importance of the objective
of this
program excuse me sorry um nhma also
supports the substance of this program
which it understands to be the supply
and maintenance of the accessible voting
system purchased using Federal Hava
funds to the municipalities for local
elections by the Secretary of State's
office which will ensure that every
polling site has at least one system and
that those systems are consistent
throughout the state of New
Hampshire the municipalities will bear
the cost of programing accessible voting
system for local elections which
although is a cost is substantially less
than if the system had to be purchased
by the municipalities
individually the municipalities will
secure the system in a manner Guided by
the Secretary of State's office while it
is in their possession following the
local election the system will return to
the Secretary of State's office for
maintenance and storage in the time
periods between
elections moving this successful pilot
program to a permanent program through
this legislation will benefit the state
and ensure that it is in compliance with
the federal Ada we urge you to recommend
this bill ought to pass I'm open to
questions are questions from the
committee seeing none thank you um are
there anyone else wishing speak on this
bill saying none we're going to uh do
two uh nine people signed up uh on the
blue sheet in support of the bill that
did not speak fin the reminder the blue
sheet is for if you wish to if you are
here and you wish to have your opinion
known but not speak so if you wish to if
you're speaking don't sign the blue
sheet we get that with the pink card so
that's why I had to do some math there
um and then on online um it was you know
it was uh pretty one-sided uh three
opposed one neutral and 111 in support
so with that we will close the public
hearing for House Bill 67 and open the
public hearing for House Bill 261
relative to election Audits and I think
representative we you get to you're
frequent flying us
today my
pleasure
um so thank you Mr chair and honorable
committee members for the record my name
is Robert warry I have the privilege of
representing Hillsboro District 13 the
great town of
Hudson um as you all are aware of uh
audits are an important uh practice to
do um in financial matters and inventor
throughout Supply chains and for
election
Integrity uh the the legislature with
the approval from the governor has
established audits for this state uh in
our attempt to strive to ensure election
Integrity um and in the uh mid November
time frame uh I participated in some
recounts that were uh performed and uh
we did the
audits uh prior to the recounts and then
did the recounts and logistically this
has some problems um typically during
recounts you have teams of lawyers and
observers as well as the candidates and
um and they're kept uh hanging around
and um uh anybody who has to be paid for
that time when essentially they're not
doing anything so what this bill
addresses is it simply moves the audits
to after the recount portion and then um
that way that allows the logistics of of
getting the recounts done immediately
and uh moving that large team of people
participating in each recount to a time
um uh earlier uh and then the audits can
be precisely done uh after the recounts
are
completed so uh and the wording is
relatively simple it just says after and
after the completion of a recount so the
audits would be done after the recount
are there any
questions are there any questions from
the committee seeing none thank you only
one other person signed up to speak for
this is deputy secretary of state Aon
Hennessy I'm representative gavy can you
again good morning again Aaron Hennessy
deputy secretary of state I just want to
let you know that our office is in favor
of this
legislation uh in the November recounts
we didn't have as many as we um could
have had we had I believe nine um one
ended up getting called off so just
eight in total but for up to T 10 state
representative races we have to do top
of the ticket recount uh Audits and
currently the law requires us to do them
before the recounts uh if we were to
have as many recounts as we had in say
2022 uh we may not have been able to
have finish the recounts in time to um
call uh you folks to take your seats for
the first Wednesday in December to be
sworn in so we are in support of this
legislation that allows us to move the
audits until after the recounts happy
take questions questions from the
committee seeing none thank you
um you see I scheduled the quick bill
behind the long bill was thinking um
anyone else wishing to speak to this
bill um thank you seeing none um there
was no one signed up on the blue sheet
and and online there was five in support
and three opposed with that we will be
closing the public hearing on House Bill
261 and opening the public hearing for
House Bill
340 FN relative to electioneering by
public employees and representative
merer is recognized in for the purpose
thank you Mr chair and members of the
committee again my name is Lisa merer I
represent Hillsboro District 44 I am
here to
introduce and support HP 340 FN which
expands our current electioneering law
this bill is important so that public
employees who we pay with our tax
dollars remain new neutral during state
and local elections and serve all
citizens regardless of political
affiliation this past election employees
of our Town's Public Library put
together a politically biased and
leading questionnaire to candidates they
claimed that most of the questions were
provided by the community after filing a
right to no request that was found to
not be the case they had gathered two
questions from the community and the
rest from other publicly funded
employees who work for our town a
library staff member even emailed the
library director asking if any feedback
was received about suggested candidate
questions the library director responded
saying and this is quote none of the
questions are stellar and some of them
will need to be Rewritten if we want to
use them end quote she also said the
library staff would select all final
questions
nothing in the current law stops these
public employees from putting out a
questionnaire that includes a question
like why is representative so and so a
bad candidate for office this sets a bad
precedent that seems to allow for
electioneering that could lead to
unequal access to resources or
information favoring incumbents or
specific candidates which goes against
principles of fairness and equal
opportunity these public employees also
help in our town organize political
events public employees should not be
using government property equipment or
their time that we pay for for these
kinds of
activities
why we have other
volunteer-led organizations that could
do the same thing voters can educate
themselves about their candidates
without this kind of
involvement electioneering by public
employ employees can undermine public
trust in government institutions as it
may appear that taxpayer resources are
being used to influence elections
unfairly I ask you to vote for this good
bill that expands the law to prevent
public employees from electioneering
thank you will you be taking questions
representative Maser I'll try Okay are
there questions from the
committee representative Mirad thank you
um my understanding is that this
bill um simply adds the following
sections to the existing law sections
three a b c are being added to the law
everything else is the same and
section 6 AB c d so it's the subheadings
ABC 3 ABC and and six ABCD by the way
six should be four it's a it's a typo in
the bill but I'm going to call it six
because it's labeled six in the bill
correct right
now so it's just those subheadings ABC
and ABCD they're being added is that
correct yes yeah spe thank you for the
question specifically uh referencing uh
surveys and organizing political
activities I mean there's a little bit
more to that but that was the main gist
of the
expansion can I have followup question
sure um yeah an organiz thank you for
the taking another question um so so
Section 3 ABC introduces examples of
electioneering that were not in the the
current
law um these examples are not
um exhaustive there could be many other
examples of electioneering that these
examples don't contain so they're just
sort of a kind of adding a for example
ABC to the law where right now the law
doesn't have that for example ABC
um and and section c includes organizing
surveys that are political that just
leads to a specific question which
is if um University of New Hampshire
professors are considered public
employees and if a University of New
Hampshire professor participates in in
polling like doing a UNH poll of New
Hampshire Public Opinion maybe about an
issue or a c or a race would that kind
of pulling undertaken by UNH employees
be forbidden by this by this example in
the
law well I I thank you I believe
currently you know public
employees correct me if I'm wrong can
facilitate these kinds of activities but
the in it's the problem is is the
influencing of the political activities
which in our town is happening a
lot one more representative and least
keep the question a little short shorter
if you don't mind because we do we are
executing this bill today that's my
point so I understand I think I'm
raising profound and and severe problems
with the bill that need to be aired but
I I'll pass on this follow-up question I
don't think I've I don't think I've
wasted the committee's time so far thank
you representative Howard thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking my
question so I understand in your
testimony that you brought up a
situation that occurred this past fall
uh with the gtown library and I
understand that there was a lawsuit uh
that had occurred with that situation
what was the outcome of that
lawsuit um he it was basically that it
wasn't in his well in the lawsuit it it
wasn't part of their purview so that it
should go
to you know the AG or whatever so yeah
it it wasn't in whose perview sorry part
of the court
system because it was in the court
system further questions representative
Lane
representative Newsome thank you Mr
chair and thank you for taking the
question um do you find it confusing if
two different statutes use the term
definitions I I mean I don't I'm not
sure what you're referencing the uh you
have a follow you requesting a follow
some followup to add clarification to
the question yes um the bill in front of
us affects electioneering for public
employees in 659 col 44A
65944 prohibits electioneering by
election officials which uses the same
definition today that's not being
changed so is there a reason why you
seek to change one definition of
election heing while leaving the
previous one the same because this is
specific to public employees that we pay
with our tax dollars you know and and
the people that those employees that got
involved in our previous election and
they're planning on doing it again um
you know is our library is our towns in
is our parks and recck Department Etc so
those are all people that we pay tax
dollars and their time should can be
utilized elsewhere not putting out
information that's influencing our
elections voters or adults they can do
this on their own we do not need this
this outside piece to come in and their
questions these this 12-point survey or
whatever that they put out was very
biased very leading and there's nothing
in our current law that prevents that
and that's what this is this expands
that so this cannot happen
again further questions representative
Lane
um along what uh representative Mirad I
think was was going to it seems that
we're defining election in two places
and you're trying to expand it by
example in 44- a is that really
necessary when in
44 it says specifically designed to
influence the vote of a voter on any
question or office you would think that
would be clear but in but in thisa in
our case it is not so we were we were
people were at we were specifically
asked the law needs to be clarified so
that they cannot do this anymore um
because it makes it very unfair in our
town um to certain people who are
running for office of of the C the
information that they put out regularly
is is very biased and um and makes it so
that candidates do not want to
participate because of that and that's
that shouldn't be a follow up yes just
follow up um thank you um was was in the
lawsuit did the judge say anything about
the definition of election ear I can't
comment to the lawsuit I wasn't a part
that further questions from the
committee representative P mban thank
you Mr chairman uh so none this would
not prohib prohibit communities from
using a room in the library like a a
meeting room or prohibit um Town
officials from making a public area
available for members of the public to
ask questions of candidates maybe a
candidate Forum where members of the ca
public just simply ask questions at that
meeting yes thank you for that question
and that does happen currently so our
Our Town Lions Club you know we open up
there's a a room that they open up for a
candidate's night and that's that's the
way it should be um that is a
volunteer-led organization and they have
that right to do
that further questions from the
committee seeing none thank you
representative yes representative
Gilmore thank you um I'm having a little
problem with room uh three um and uh
subsection B um so it seems like as I'm
reading this
you're saying that no Public Employee
could make any public statement against
any
candidate correct thank you yes as
serving in their role as a Public
Employee what they do personally is
their business um on their side but they
if they are you know it's during work
time and they are on let's say the the
parks and rep page um you any any part
of anything that they're putting out
publicly in their role as a Public
Employee okay when they're on the clock
as a Public Employee yes so in okay
thank you yep all right thank you thank
you representative Maser um next up is
Hennessy good morning again Aaron
Hennessey deputy secretary of state our
department does not take a position on
this bill but I would point out uh that
in 652 under the general provisions of
the election laws it does have a
definition for election ear so I would
hope that that would be um just to make
sure uh for the enforcement aspects of
this and for any questions our
department gets that it's just clear on
what the definition of electioneering is
actually that's it happy to take
questions questions from the committee
representative gim can you turn your mic
off thanks that just avoiding uh a
problem in the future if you know what I
mean and represented Mirad I'll uh also
same thing for you would you like to
turn your mic off there you go all right
any questions for the Secretary of State
seeing none thank you represent uh I
almost called represent of Hennessy my
apologize deputy secretary of state
Hennessy um next up is Dave Nelson from
thank you Mr chairman and through you to
the members uh my name is Dave Nelson uh
I am the dairy Town
moderator um I have a problem with
potential unintended um consequences
with the new section Roman 3 little
C which prohibits any Town um or other
Municipal Public Employee from
participating in specifically forums the
town of Derry has a long history of um
running candidate for forums and
typically those are moderated by either
the town moderator or School District
moderator is appropriate um all the
questions come from U members of the
audience and um the event is live
streamed over the town's Community
Access cable TV network um obviously
getting people to attend these things is
important and I just want to make
sure that there will not be a dampening
effect on Town employees who help
organize this for example the IT
department that lists um the date and
time um of the event on the town website
um without advocating for any position
or candidate um or the town um um
Community Access media people who come
and bring their cameras and um film and
and transmit um the proceedings um live
um those folks are Town
employees um they are acting within the
scope of their official duties
um but they are assisting in
coordinating a forum and if if this can
be interpreted to um make them concerned
or leery about continuing that um I
would like to see an amendment to to
clarify that concern on my part I'll
answer any questions okay are there
questions from the
committee seeing none thank you next up
good morning chairman Barry and members
of the committee I'm darus hoeny a
former School Board member from NASA in
2009 I filed two right to no requests
asking for Union emails sent through the
National School District Network for the
last two Mondays prior to the municipal
election from these emails I found that
the American Federation of teachers are
aatf teachers union president initiated
an email to his union leaders with
election information including a link to
the Nashville teachers union pack um
called cope each of these union leaders
then he sent it out to all the different
schools like 20 or a couple dozen and
each of these union leaders forward this
email to union members to in the
respective schools nashille has 17
schools the teachers union president
represents 2,000 employees in the
nashille school district a union member
also complained to me as a sitting board
member that she was given political
flyers in a union meeting held in school
school buildings which I forwarded to
the AG's office the school board
attorney attorney Tom Clawson affirmed
that it was electioneering and told me
to save all the information as I filed a
complaint with the New Hampshire AG's
office he indicated that it was more
than enough to go to the plrb the Labor
Relations Board for unfair practices I
didn't get into that with him at the
time however the AG's office declared
there was no election Heering because
the union president was not a district
employee Nasha has an unusual situation
where the union president has a memo of
understanding in the Union contract with
the district guaranteeing him a salary
benefits step increases payments to the
state P pension fund and increases in
his position of seniority among union
members in return the union repays the
district These funds and apparently this
mou allowed him to ele Sher at
will I asked the AG's office to
reconsider sending him a chart of all
the emails of all the union members as
they were District employees they were
using District computers Network
District networks during school hours
according to the date and time stamps on
their respective emails as they
forwarded the same election material
from the union president to their
respective union members and again the
AG's office found no
electioneering my concern is not only
for identifying Prosecuting
electioneering but making sure there's a
suitable deterrent or punishment in
place election results in a distortion
of our election outcomes compromising
taxpayers for four years in our School
District the employees involved should
be removed from the district as they've
undermined our election removing
unfavorable candidates from office I
just wanted to point out that our Union
also in the past has paid union members
$150 requires the union members to stand
at the polls holding signs Republicans
and Democrats Al light they don't file
Their donation like they their expenses
if they Union donates to certain
candidates they don't file that with the
city it's a it's the city ordinance and
the AG doesn't care they haven't done
that for decades so we're kind of in a
black hole in ASA and any help would be
appreciated thank you thank you are
there will you be taking questions Miss
Hy certainly are there questions from
the
committee yes representative weing so
your your request to the AG concerned
the president of the Union is that
correct it it concerned electioneering
of the whole group of the whole group so
he he identified it as just the
president
I asked for reconsideration gave him a
chart I can give you all this
information where I had the names of all
the the employees The District employees
the time date stamp and what they sent
followup followup so I I could see where
actually the the president not being a
district member would be immune from the
election aing charges but everyone else
who then
distributed the uh notice notifications
would be be subject to the election
earing uh Provisions is that how you
would see it yes that's how the attorney
Clawson who was our school board
attorney represented it when he saw it
he said it was open and shut but the
Attorney General didn't and I wasn't
about to file a lawsuit against the
Attorney General we had other problems
and as a school board
member further questions from the
Committee hearing none thank you so much
thank you uh next up is uh Sarah Burke
Association hello my name is Sarah Burke
Cohen and I am a legislative advocate
for the New Hampshire Municipal
Association nhma is here to oppose hb340
hb340 is overly Broad and vague for
example making public statements in
favor of or against any candidate
political party or measure seems to
indicate that a Public Employee would be
barred from organic discussions about
candidates or political parties that may
take place during any given work day
nhma finds the language in this bill
would create such confusion that a
Public Employee may not know what speech
is prohibited it would create a chilling
effect in which a Public Employee would
be fear ful that any speech even speech
protected by the first amendment was
prohibited and so not engage in it at
all for these reasons nhma opposes hb340
and urges you to do the same I'm I'm
open to questions are there questions
from the committee seeing none thank you
thank you um last up that I have for
pink card is Brian Hawkins from the Nea
thank you Mr thank you Mr chairman uh
members of the committee for the record
Brian Hawkins representing Nea New
Hampshire we represent um uh numerous uh
local unions across the state uh in k12
and and some in higher education as well
um and we're here in opposition to
hb340 um which we see as uh
a large expansion of the electioneering
uh statute certainly support uh the the
statute as it stands um but this uh
vastly expands 659
44A um and a couple of things I'll just
uh so I don't repeat previous
testimony um in Roman in section one
Roman 3 one of the changes that is made
to the current statute is the
um addition of in any way designed
instead of specifically designed and
then also um ads or having the effect of
influencing and so that that is a change
I think it was already raised in earlier
testimony about the addition of the
uh
ABCD um and and the um and the
subsequent SE uh sections after that but
uh you know that that is seems to
capture a lot more than the current
statute at least um you know so a
question would be so now someone can say
well you know Brian said in hallway
whatever that I uh internalize to mean
something else which is not something
that I meant um and it had the effect of
influencing a vote um so uh that is a
concern that this would lead to
um uh inadvertent uh issues there and
then this is significant because of
course the the effect of this is that
someone could be charged with a
misdemeanor and so
um uh I think that's the central concern
that I would just add to what was
already brought up that this is vague
and
subjective and um would be difficult to
enforce will you be taking questions I'm
happy to take any questions if I if I
can answer them are questions from the
Committee hearing none thank you um I
don't have anyone else signed up just
speaking any pink cards does anyone else
wish to speak thank you see none uh the
blue sheet uh both people on the blue
sheet spoke so technically no one on the
blue sheet um and then online there were
five in support five opposed and with
that I will close the public hearing for
House Bill
340 and we have to stand for a minute we
did it we got back on schedule so I'll
okay think we're okay it is now 11:30
thank you for didn't fill out a no
worries he will get you a pink card in a
second uh since pink cards go to you it
kind of works out um all right so we're
going to open up the public hearing on
House Bill 160 relative to the contents
of the pre-election certificate and
we're going to um recognize uh
representative burm for the purpose of
introduction um just so you guys know I
I'm going to per permit representative
Burnham to rejoin the committee after
she testifies she won't participate in
the hearing for asking questions but
she'll continue her clerk duties um so
I'm going to I'm going to unless
somebody wants to do that I'm going to
go ahead and let her do her job and I
don't I don't think there's going to be
an objection to that but she won't
participate in the hearing
okay I I had to I had to beg her to do
the job to begin with so I don't think
there people shooting to do the job I
it' be so appropriate I mean you know
just just for time just for all time
sakes no it's okay just for all time
sakes you know just for all time sakes
for for those wondering what what the
joke is that representative Grill was
our very good clerk from last term uh
and we miss her dearly representative
Burnham uh make sure you get your mic on
but we are ready to
go thank you Mr chairman and thank you
members of the committee um as the prime
sponsor of HB 160 relative to the
contents of pre-election certificate I
believe that all ballets matter and this
bill provides tabulation of absente
ballots for pre-election through
election day accountability just as
official election ballots are counted
before elections and during election day
either as spoiled ballots casted ballots
or remaining ballots so should absentee
ballots be required to be counted before
they are distributed to voters they
should be should they become spoiled as
well as any that are remaining absentee
ballots at the close of election day
currently absentee ballots are only
counted when cast on Election Day as an
absentee Ballot or as a substitute for
an official ballot Just as in RSA
65831 the counting of ballots prior to
the opening of polls official ballots
are counted before and after elections
so too the absentee ballots should be
counted before and after elections by
treating our absentee ballots with
better accountability this small but yet
important tabulation process will
provide more confidence in our election
ballot process many clerks are already
keeping track of absentee ballots as
they enter and flow through their office
for personal tracking therefore this
process may be easily implemented and
provide the public with better knowledge
of the number of absentee ballots
received and remaining at the end of
election day thank you for your
consideration in passing this bill okay
will you be taking questions from the
committee representative yes are there
okay I saw representative C first but
ranking I will come to
you U thank you for taking my question
um in here it it takes away the uh
reference to the total number of ballots
re received and just talks about the
absentee ballots can you explain why we
don't want to know about the total
ballot yes so that is actually counted
um in in on the um I believe it's the
post election certificate on the day of
Elections those ballots are uh counted
on that portion so there's two sides uh
like a balance sheet um and absentee
ballots are only recognized on the
second side which is the ones that are
received in the machine or if they're
used as an official
ballot as a uh as for the official
ballots for election day those are
counted before once the clerk receives
them and then any remaining ones are
also counted at the end and accounted
for we're just looking at having the
same process done for absentee
ballots thank
you representative Lane um thank you Mr
chair and representative Burnham thanks
for taking the question um when I read
the bill it talks about a pre-election
certificate and then in the um in the
calculation you're having the number of
absentee ballots spoiled and the number
of absentee ballots remaining at the
close of polls how can you do this
before the election so that yeah I'm
sorry yes so um that
is that's the challenging part but the
clerk does have that sheet uh for
elections and they'll know at the end of
Elections and be able to write that same
number on on the pre-election
certificate just to kind of keep order
of the absentee ballot on the
pre-election certificate but that number
um is is staying with the absentee
ballot versus on the um election day
certificate it's kind of split up due to
um a bill that did
that um one more question followup um so
I I guess this isn't a question but I
suggest you might want to change change
the name of the certificate because it's
no longer just pre-election if we go
this route but also there's another bill
coming at us with some changes like this
I think it's HB 158 and I haven't read
it carefully are you familiar with that
bill and are they the are they similar
or do you know I am not familiar with
that one okay thank
you okay uh further questions from the
committee seeing none thank you
representative bur and please please
please please rejoin us because you do
not want to see my notes
um next up is deputy secretary of state
Aon
Hennessy thank you Mr chair members of
the committee Aaron Hennessy deputy
secretary of
state I have a few comments on this
legislation I think it um does a few
good things um and that would be easier
for some of the clerks and moderators
work but I do want to point out and I
will be handing out the pre-election and
the post-election certificates after I
speak per Mr chair's uh Direction but
the legislature changed I believe it was
two years ago now um The Lang the name
of these certificates one is the
pre-election certificate and one is the
post-election certificate and from my um
perspective on um looking at these
certificates the L the naming of these
certificates was very helpful because it
helped moderators and clerks understand
when they had to be done the
pre-election certificate specifically
requires that the clerk and the
moderator both certify that before the
election begins they have handc counted
or they have counted it doesn't say hand
count in the law but they have counted
the number of official ballots that they
have received from the Secretary of
State and they've examined them so they
they know that oh these are the actual
Ward one's ballots and not ward two
ballots so they don't start off the day
um with the incorrect ballots and they
know how many they have um that
information is also useful for the
moderator to use in the post-election
certificate the pre-election certificate
also requires if you are an electronic
ballot County Town the clerk and the
moderator to certify that they have
looked for evidence that the um device
has been tested um prior to the election
and to put the serial numbers of those
devices in um and to sign their name so
it does two important things the number
of official ballots and the number and
the um electronic ballot counting
devices prior to um putting them into
place at an election I think if they the
language of this bill were to require
postelection information on the
certificate it would get very confusing
to moderators and clerks because um they
would be coming back to the certificate
twice um I think perhaps a separate
certificate might be uh um in order or a
separate worksheet um the in general the
moderators don't have control over the
absentee ballots um in the clerk's
office so it may be a clerk function um
while I'm not advocating for that I
would say that if you were to do
that um there are several data points
that you are missing and that is the
number of absentee ballots use as
official election day ballots so if a
polling place runs out of official
election day ballots they sometimes have
to use absentee ballots um the number of
absentee ballots not returned um by a
voter the number of rejected absentee
ballots that have not been cast the
number of duplicate mailings uh
unfortunately as time goes on we've seen
that um sometimes uh voters do not get
their absentee ballot they've requested
we occasionally in our office receive
absentee ballots back months and months
later that for some reason were not
delivered to a voter or if um in the
example of this past fall when there
were severe storms sometimes mail just
got destroyed so there's there's
instances where somebody needs uh more
than one ballot mailed to them because
they didn't receive it so this this
language here doesn't account for that
um it also doesn't account for um when
an absentee ballot is used on Election
Day to a voter who's unable to come into
a polling location um they are a
curbside voter and the law does allow
for an absentee ballot to be hand
delivered to that person um and
collected by the moderator um so that's
some information that is missing from
this in order to track absentee ballots
um one of the things I will say and on
page two um lines 4 through 11 this
would effectively remove the requirement
of the ballots cast information that is
currently on the um return of votes form
so now when a clerk um fills in the
return of votes form with the election
information the ballot the the number of
votes for each candidate the number of
undervotes and the number of overvotes
they also um are filling in the ballots
cast information so this would remove
that information from the return of
votes um and it would just be on the um
post-election certificate which it
already is with the exception of the
federal office only ballots we don't
break those out on the post elction
certificate but we could do that um very
easily um so that is one thing that a
clerk or a moderator might be excited to
see that they don't have to fill this
information in multiple times I would
ask that um because this information is
being taken off the return of votes form
right now the postelection certificate
the law allows the moderators to
complete this within 48 Hours of the
close of an election um unless the
Secretary of State demands that it be
done at a different time and I think
that because the post-election
certificate is the actual reconciliation
for an election that this certificate
should be done on Election night um the
ballot cast information is there the
comparison of ballot cast information is
there sum of all votes is there and the
voter participation which is the number
of Voters checking in on the checklist
as having um received received a ballot
that day so that is very important part
of election night
reconciliation um and so the moderator
has this information already on Election
night so it would be helpful if this
information were to be due on Election
night and returned um by the clerk um
just like in um on lines 11 through
13 separate information the pre-election
is already returned on Election after
the election by the clerk to our office
office I have you take any questions and
I'm going to hand these out so you can
see what the pre-election and
post-election certificate already um
require and I will say that some of the
other requirements are already on our
post elction
certificate okay will you be taking
questions from the committee
yes y sorry represent Lane I seem to be
the questioner of the day um thank you
for taking the question um just so that
I because I've never actually filled
these sheets out but if you wanted to
account for absentee ballots is the
information included in the
existing um forms or not not currently
because of all of the moving Parts with
absentee ballots um the clerks do keep
track of who has been issued an absentee
ballot um and that information is
entered into our Statewide voter
registration system and there can be
some updates to that on election day U
there are some clerks here behind me
that would be happy to talk about that
but I'm sure if asked um so I don't want
to speak for them but um so the sbrs
reporting that is printed out prior to
an election is is a piece of that
information plus all the other things
that I just talked about that happen on
Election Day to adjust
that further questions from the
committee representative
C thank you for taking my question
um are clerks allowed to take ballots to
like a local nursing home or something
like that and assist them with uh doing
the absentee Ballance or do they have to
actually be mailed thank you for the
question yes their their clerks are
allowed to do that before election
day followup follow uh so in this case
uh where it just says the number of
absentee ballots mailed to voters should
that also include or provided or
something to that effect thank you for
the question that's a good that's a good
observation uh because sometimes a voter
may come into the office and just be
hand Del hand so um perhaps delivered
and versus
mailed thank
you further more further questions from
the Committee hearing none thank you
deputy
secretary next up The Honorable Joan
Hamlet
thank you Mr
chair um my name is Joan Hamlet I am a
prior member of the election law
committee and I'm currently the
moderator of Portsmouth ward
3 so my comments are really just about
section one of this bill um regarding
the pre-election
certificate uh this bill misses the
point of the pre-election certificate
the pre-election certificate does two
things it certifies that the electronic
ballot counting devices and memory
devices were tested before the election
began and that the device seals were
present recorded and not not tampered
with and number two it certifies that
the official blank ballots that were
delivered to the polling place were
examined and counted before the election
began this important number of blank
ballots is used at the end of election
day to calculate the actual number of
ballots that were cast by the election
day voters this is a critical part of
the reconciliation that is performed
after the polls
close absentee ballots have nothing to
do with the pre-election certificate
absentee ballots are carefully recorded
by the city or town clerk on the state
uh absentee ballot list which is which
is the svrs uh list this list provides
all the data the moderator needs to
account for all the absentee ballots
cast on Election Day every single
absentee ballot submitted by voters is
accounted for there is no reason to
complicate the pre-election certificate
with the absentee ballot records that
have already been meticulously recorded
on the state absentee ballot
list if you are concerned that an
absentee ballot might be used
fraudulently how would that
happen for example if someone tampers
with and submits another person's
absentee ballot it would likely be
caught in the multi-step verification
process that that
follows the city or town clerk the
moderator and the ballot clerks all take
steps to verify that each absentee
ballot is
legitimate in addition voters May
observe the process and May challenge
any absentee ballot these protections
ensure that there is no significant
absentee ballot fraud in New Hampshire
therefore there are multiple reasons why
this bill is not needed please vote HP
160 an expedient to legislate and I do
have some written testimon testimony I
can submit and I'll take questions thank
you are there questions from the
Committee hearing none thank you and
once again it's always good seeing you
Dary oh that's fine all right so we'll
uh I so I do need you to get on the blue
sheet then
um since you're not speaking um just for
the sake and then I guess we'll go to
Daniel
Hy
sorry good morning uh Dan Hy Nash City
Clerk and I guess now speaking on behalf
of the New Hampshire City and town
clerks
Association um most of the points that I
was in conf discuss have already been
brought up um the
having a number at close of polls on the
pre-election certificate doesn't make
too much uh sense um but one of the the
other the points that was not brought up
yet uh that I wanted to hit on was that
for absentee ballots um the military
overseas the U aabas we email those out
and I just want to make sure that that's
kind of accounted for if you're doing
some type of election absentee inventory
we get an email ballot from the
Secretary of State's office that we can
email out if these particular voters uh
request it that way so I currently now
do inventory my ballots when we get them
from the Secretary of State say they
said they sent us a th I count them to
make sure that we have a th we bundle
them up into hundreds um if you run out
on Election Day you can use those
following a procedure so I do currently
already inventory the ballots but then
you got to take into account these these
other factors of the uh uaba OTS uh that
are emailed out so I just want to make
sure that that's on um the committee's
radar uh all the other things I believe
have already been um discussed a few
kind of concerns that we had um
regarding the pre-election versus post
election to where the numbers are
actually accounted for so I don't want
to just rehash that but i' be open to
any any questions other questions from
the Committee hearing none thank you and
then last up is Mr Dave Nelson uh from
dairy and and um representing if you
could grab the blue sheet for me for
this
Bill thank you Mr chairman and through
you um to the members I am Dave Nelson
the Dair Town moderator um I want to
reiterate and Echo and support all of
the comments uh that have been um given
so far um and just summarize that um I
think it would make um administration of
Elections very difficult for uh the
moderator and and and as well for the
clerk um if the number of absentee
ballots spoiled and the number of
absentee ballots remaining at the close
of the polls were on the pre-election
certificate because that is typically
completed and signed um well before the
election um if if somebody wanted to
move that to the post-election
certificate that would be um perhaps a
wonderful thing but it does not belong
on the pre-election certificate thank
you any questions questions from the
committee all right seeing none thank
you with that I no one else signed up to
speak um on the blue sheet there were
two people signed in opposed that did
not speak and then online there were
three in support and seven opposed with
that I'm closing the public hearing on
House Bill 160 um representative Lane
are you good to go into executive
session I know it's it's noticed but I'm
just ask asking as a courtesy um I would
I think we need to recess given that we
just finished the public hearings and
would you like we need to recess for
caucus how long would you like
um I don't know do you want to do lunch
or what time do you have to get out of
here I need to be out of here at like 12
I need to be out of here 12:45 is so I
wasn't planning on going to lunch but if
you'd like to recess that's fine yeah
let's recess can you 20 minutes with
that be enough well we'll see we'll try
to make it okay um so let's return at um
math
12:15 so I'll see you guys back at 12:15
all
right the Democrats will be in room 403
um representative Lane hold on before
you go as a courtesy let me give you
amendment we'll uh Republicans will go
to
300 if the I didn't count it up but I've
got enough but that's you need more let
me
know uh and for submitted written
testimony uh I'm going to organize it at
my desk so if you want copies of what
was submitted that you didn't get around
cuz I don't like to go around just come
and let me know and I'll get it for you
all right all right and we'll see
never
right
e
okay uh we're going is it
12:15 yep okay all right all right going
to gavel in executive session for the
house election law
committee and hold on my calendar got
buried
uh oh I need there we go that's what I
need okay uh so we'll start off election
law the right way uh we're going to um
open up the executive session on House
Bill 67 FNA relative to agreements with
the Secretary of State for the use of
accessible voting machines
representative weary is recognized for a
motion
uh Mr chair I'd like to move that the
bill ought to pass there's a there's a
um motion of ought to pass
representative Lane is seconding yes all
right um representative we wish you
would you wish to speak to your motion
yes um so the pilot program goes through
the mid portion of this year um in the
second half of this year um it's my
understanding that there are
approximately 11 City elections that
will occur and and um so uh some of the
concerns about uh you know towns not
being prepared and and delaying the
enactment of this uh to the 1 of of
January for
2026 um seems to me to
be um not necessary not required in this
instance I think um it's important that
we uh really protect I mean Governor aot
talked about protecting our most
vulnerable able during her inaugural
address and if we're not protecting our
most vulnerable on election days then
we're we're not serving our citizens
properly so I think I think we really
need to uh move forward with this um
there's not an undue burden that this is
creating in the second half of this year
and then as proposed it um you know the
towns and uh would have full rather full
enactment in 2026 for their uh March
elections then and um this I think gives
them ample time to prepare for that so
um for those reasons I believe that it's
prudent for this committee to move
forward with this bill and uh really
protect our vulnerable voters at this
time thank
you further discussion on the bill uh
representative pram O'Brien thank you Mr
chairman and I agree with all of that
but I I think we all remember
when last term someone with a a a vision
disability talked about feeling like
they did not have a private vote because
of the way things had been I want to uh
keep protecting the the right to a
private vote for all citizens and uh I
think we heard some testimony today that
told told us about how important that is
to that community and we should do
everything possible despite some of the
challenges that the the Secretary of
State's office has has talked about we
should just keep going forward with this
and protect that Community above
everything else I thank you further uh
comments on the bill seeing none Madam
clerk are you
ready um the motion is ought to pass um
and the clerk will call oh just say
because we don't have my vice chair I'm
going to go first normally I would go
last U but today I'm going first so and
it's a days of it's the day of like the
worst first day ever where nothing will
be like this again hopefully um uh the
role chairman Barry chair votes
yes representative paduma Brian
yes representative Burnham yes
representative wary yes
representative
wood
Leia okay yes she declared thank you uh
where am
I representative C
yes representative
representative Lane yes representative
Ward yes representative
Gilmore yes representative Mirad
yes representative Grill
yes representative wilham yes
representative Nome yes representative
Howard
yes okay so did I miss one you missed
the you miss qua which is now mer oh I'm
so sorry representative merer yes okay
okay so it's 18 17 17 yet okay uh with
that the motion of O to pass passes 17
to zero representative Harley buia
declared a conflict with the F's office
and did not participate um is there any
objection to this bill being placed onto
the consent
calendar oh it has a fiscal note so it
does not matter it does not get a
consent calendar um so never mind um
representative weie would you be
okay and that's that okay first one best
one all right with that I'm going to
close the executive session for House
Bill
67 uh and we will open up the executive
session for House Bill 160
representative Burnham you are
recognized for a
motion I'm sorry I'm a little um
that's
okay pass yes uh motion to ought to pass
160 representative Harley bolia seconds
the motion we're now on discussion of
the motion of ought to pass on House
bill we want to discussion on the bill
so yes if You' like to be recognized
representative representative L
recognized I think given the testimony
that we heard on the many fl La of this
bill I think if we're going to consider
it we should at least give the uh give
representative bernham time to make the
changes that were that were almost
unanimously
proposed um because to dump this over uh
on the moderators as it is is against
the advice of the clerks the municipal
State further discussion on the
bill representative BM pleas speak to
your
motion I'm willing to do that if that is
okay if if
that's yep that's fine we can recess the
bill if you'd like um because we haven't
taken we haven't started the voting
process so uh I will recess House Bill
160 um when we come back from 160 the
motion of ought to pass and the second
are still standing so we will when we
reconvene that we will go right back
into that motion we won't have to do
that again um and I left my amendment in
my office which was a real move of
Genius so uh we're going to stand in
unless it's right here no we're going to
stand in recess for two minutes while
the chair apologizes profusely for
wasting people's time um goes and grabs
the
amendment
e
okay uh any objection to coming back are
we are we still miss do M step out I'm
sorry we M right pass that on down Okay
um
let's do this one real fast um we're
going to open up the executive session
for House Bill
261 um which was not noticed but with
the consent of the ranking member we're
going to execute correct representative
Lane correct okay um so this is relative
to election audits um I'll make the
motion of ought to pass is there a
second I'll second okay representative
Lane seconds is there any I'll speak to
the motion um um this is my bill so
sorry I didn't do the hearing but with
the vice chair gone I had to send
somebody else to do the hearings on my
bill so I apologize that's why I didn't
ask questions during uh this hearing or
340 was I was in this kind of No Man's
Land of I have to run the committee I
don't have my vice chair but it's my
bill um so I tried to stay out of the
hearings so um representative we's
testimony in the hearing was dead on
which is right now we when we do the
10 uh audits for the State Rep races we
the law says it has to be done before um
so what was happening is is both sides
were getting all of their volunteers
there um and then they were hanging out
for like 2 hours while this recount
occurred um because you couldn't tell
people who were interested in the
recount when it would actually begin
because they were doing this audit right
before so all the bill does I hate
expressions like that all the bill does
but all the bill does is change the word
before to after um so that we can do the
recount first um and then the audit will
still occur um so uh I think it's
probably the I don't want to say it's
the most boring Bill I've ever sponsored
but it's definitely it's definitely up
there um anyways that's my that's my any
other comments questions on the
bill uh representative Howard yeah I
just wanted to say as somebody who did
have a recount this past session uh
having to sit around for three four
hours waiting for that audit to finish
uh was kind of a waste of everybody's
time and I am going to be supporting
this Bill thank you other questions uh
yes representative C oh thank you um I
just wanted to point out that the
original concept and I was the person
who originated the uh audit thing was
that the uh original intent was that
because the ballots were in the recount
area the boxes were open the seals
broken that it would be convenient to uh
in addition
do an audit of the top of the ballot uh
races and
as that concept the um audit is
secondary to the recount the recount is
why everybody was there thank you okay
all right I assume that means you're
supporting it it sounds it sounded like
yes okay all right all right any other
questions comments on the bill okay um
hearing none the clerk will call the
role on House Bill the motion of aop
261 chairman Barry chair votes
yes representative pum O'Brien yes
representative Burnham yes
representative warry yes representative
wood yes representative Harvey Olia yes
representative C yes representative uh
gzowski
yes representative toner yes
representative Maser yes representative
Lane yes representative Ward yes
representative Gilmore yes
representative Mirad yes representative
Grill yes representative wilham yes
representative Nome yes representative
Howard yes so it's 18 okay yay okay with
that uh House Bill 261 will be reported
out uh as ought to pass uh 18 to Zer is
there any objection to this one being on
the consent calendar because it does not
have a fiscal note all hearing none and
uh since I released this onto the world
I will take care of the committee report
myself so let me write that down all
right um oh just a side note by
committee reports um would really love
them this evening um when we get into
the flow of things I'll be a little more
strict about that um but with the amount
of bills we have we can't be I don't
want to be chasing down reports so um I
threatened last year to write people's
reports for them if they didn't and then
a lot of you took me up on that um which
so
uh sounds I'm I'm happy to I'm happy to
pin a report and put your name on
representative Wilhelm I don't know if
though um Okay so we've recessed we only
have one left um going to open up the
um executive session on House Bill 340
FN um I will move I'll make a motion of
ought to pass is there a
second representative Harley bu seconds
I also have an amendment uh which I
believe everyone has copies of now if
you don't I have extra copies I gave
some to the ranking member um but if you
need some raise your hand happy to send
her down one
two uh Harley representative Harley bu
oh
okay okay um and I got your guys' copies
Amendment do you need another one
representative Lane okay I'm going to
2025-the
head is it does fix that numeration
error um once again this was another one
of the bills where I should have been
doing the introduction but without the
vice chair wasn't here um and
representative Lisa Maser had to field
those questions so I will try to answer
some of the questions that came up in
the hearing now um but I didn't think it
would be appropriate since I was
chairing it to be doing that um so uh
the first thing is it does make some
changes uh other than just adding
specific examples it does change the
word specifically designed to design or
having the effect of um this is
because the the original the way the
original bill was written it was
supposed to be broad it was supposed to
be interpreted broad I went I very
familiar with this statute I went
through uh its Genesis which included uh
at the time representative Buckley from
Manchester um was the Prime sponsor of
the original Law and the it was supposed
to be interpreted very broadly and for
whatever reason the department of
justice has decided to take a very
narrowly tailored reading of it um which
was not the intent of the legislature so
the reason why there's two definitions
of electioneering um which is true um
there already are two definitions of
electioneering in the statute there's
the one that covers the whole statute
and then there's the one right now that
covers specifically 44A um and this was
by I know that the original law was
supposed to be interpreted broadly is
the legislature would have not created a
special definition for electioneering by
public employ
if it didn't want it to be broad um so
we have multiple examples of what I
believe are abuses of this law um
representative Maser spoke to the gtown
public libraries um uh survey which
might as well have read why are
Republicans bad explain why um and the
doj's response to that was oh well you
can answer it as you see fit you can
refute the question so you can refute
the question that's biased against you
uh and all of your political opponents
get to just answer the question because
it's framed in a way to make to attempt
to make them uh at least push their
issue position so I have distributed um
something that came across my desk and
if you'd like copies of it um this this
came out on January 6th of this year um
so this is from
sau39 covering the town of amher so I'll
I'll read very quickly uh we're excited
to share some news with you on Monday
January 6 so 3 days notice 3 days notice
um a film crew will be at Wilkin School
Gathering footage for a new video
project uh this project aims to
highlight areas of our building that
could benefit from updates supporting
educational efforts for the upcoming uh
Wilkins building initiative the crew
will be primarily filming interviews
with staff administrators and some
families however they'll also capture
footage in hallways and classrooms while
no students will be specifically filmed
or featured some children may appear in
the background children may appear in
the background uh as a part of a general
or b-roll shots if your child is not is
on the non-photo list we'll ensure
they're not included if you have any
questions please let me know uh
superintendent Michael Barry no relation
although my brother's name is Michael
his last name is Barry but no relation
um same spelling so he got the spelling
right I'll give him that um and what
that letter with that three-day notice
to parents fails to mention is that for
the previous three elections there has
been a uh warrant article um so I think
this I think in 2024 it was worn article
133 where they were pushing to have the
town and SAU appropriate the SAU excuse
me appropriate funds for the building
renovation so my my complaint here is
not I'm asking the committee don't look
at this from oh I want the buildings
renovated look at this from the they're
sending in a film crew with the express
purpose of pushing a position that will
soon be on the ballot and was on the
ballot three times before and rejected
three times before so the reason why I
wrote this so broadly is because it is
being abused and they are finding every
single loophole to get around it um
public employees in the commission of
their duties should be neutral Arbiters
in everything and we shouldn't be trying
to drag the courts in into what is
neutral um the definition should be
broad which is why I wrote it to being
designed or having the effect of because
in the case of gwn Public Library they
said oh well we didn't Design This
survey like this we took input from the
community um a right to no request
revealed that that was just basically
made up um they generated the there was
a state it was a gtown public employee
survey that they were then P sending to
candidates and then publishing on the
website uh I have heard things that I
have not been able to substantiate of
teachers putting leaflets into backpacks
I don't know if that's true or not I've
had multip people tell me it happens um
but I don't have any evidence in front
of me it has to stop it's currently a
misdemeanor so I'm not making it a
misdemeanor it's currently a misdemeanor
um in regards to the lawsuit the lawsuit
was tossed because they said you
couldn't bring standing in 659 only the
AG could bring could bring the lawsuit
forward uh we have a separate bill for
that to address that one the the the
judge actually did not take a position
on the merits of the case unfortunately
um so what I have done is I've written
the bill in a way that I believe
actually addresses the original intent
of the bill which was if you are a a
Public Employee stay out of the
elections it's not your job to opine in
it your job is to do your job and go
home what you do when you go home by the
way is totally your business if the Nea
wants to put out a survey of their
members they're more than welcome to do
that and they're more than welcome to
put it on the nea's website um and and
do that but you don't use taxpayer
resources to do this um so a couple of
things uh the gentleman from dairy
brought up that the moderator hosts a
forum the moderator is not considered an
employee under 27 under RSA 273 um the
moderator is elected by popular vote so
it doesn't it doesn't apply to the
moderator now and it won't apply to the
moderator after um what it does do is it
does add directors and people in
appointed positions um to the um to the
list of people that cannot elect
so the purpose of that being is once
again gtown Public Library the gtown
public library is going to declare that
their Library director is an appointed
position and thus not a public employee
under the section of RSA that this uses
the section of RSA that this uses to
define a Public Employee is in regards
to basically Union negotiations so I
don't know why the original drafters of
this section use that it's kind of a
clunky definition in my opinion but I
didn't change that so the definition
stays the same except it as in directors
um so if you are a taxpayer if you are a
public employee in the commission of
your duties right you can't electioneer
things that you can still
do a Democrat Town committee or
republican Town committee can still hold
their meeting at a library you can still
have candidates walk in parades you can
still have political stuff at fairs all
of that was intentionally put in but
what you can't do but and the staff is
allowed to facilitate that just no more
than they would anything else right so
they have to treat everybody equally so
in my opinion if the moderator is
putting on a forum for candidates and
the dairy Town Channel wants to go and
and film that and show that I don't have
an issue with that I don't think this
covers that that's in the commission of
their regular duties that they would do
for any Community event so you know I I
tried to when I WR wrote this to cover
everything that could possibly happen
that shouldn't happen or things that
should happen but the reality is is
people are playing games with the
statute the doj for some reason unb
notes to me is not seeking this out by
the way I submitted this letter from the
SAU to the doj three weeks ago haven't
heard a response so it's time to act
anyways that's my diar about this that's
the amendment it fixes the enumeration
it adds in the um the directors and
those who are appointed um as a part of
public employees and to representative
mad's question about surveys if it's not
designed or having the effect of
influencing the vote of the voter but
it's simp simply submitting information
I wouldn't consider that as a violation
um now if the question is released why
you know if you're using taxpayer funds
for the University of New Hampshire to
put up a question of why are Republicans
evil they shouldn't do that so that
would be that would be blocked by this I
think
yes representative your head I know that
your intention is not to Outlaw the UNH
Survey Center but I think as the law is
written it will have that effect and
it'll have it very clearly it says first
of all a a poll just a a neutral poll of
public opinion can have the effect of
changing people's minds I might support
the libertarian candidate once I see how
let's just for say say for the sake of
argument how low the libertarian
candidate is polling I may decide to
support the Republican candidate instead
so polls can have an effect on how
people vote they may not have the
intention of having an effect but
they'll have they can have an effect and
3C clearly says that organizing or
conducting surveys that are especially
political are an example of
electioneering so I think the work of
the UNH Survey Center will be outlawed
by this in so far as University
employees or public employees will be
outlined unintentionally by the way the
bill is
written further comments on the bill
questions concerns or the amendment
excuse me we on discussion of the
amendment my apologies further questions
or comments on the
amendment all right hearing none um I
did find out we don't have to take a
roll call on amendments but uh we're
going to we've done that in this
committee before so I'm going to keep
doing that unless somebody has a real
objection to it um I do I do reserve the
right if there's like some amendment in
the future that's housekeeping and
everybody's on board just to raise hands
but I get the feeling that's not going
to be the case for this one um so with
that the clerk will call the role on
Amendment
20252 H to House Bill
340 to pass yes a to no this is uh this
is on the this is the on adoption of the
amendment yes and there'll be a second
vote for a to pass as amended yes so
we're just on the amendment right now
want the roll call on the amend I I
chairman Barry chair votes
yes chairman uh sorry representative
Pome O'Brien
yes uh representative vernham yes
representative wey yes representative
wood
yes representative harv bolia
yes representative
C yes
representative gzowski
yes representative toner yes
representative major yes representative
Lane yes representative Ward
no representative Gilmore no
representative Mirad
yeah representative Grill yes
representative wilham yes representative
Nome
yes so that's 15 yes and two Nays okay
so with that the amendment carries uh
I'll now move um ought to pass on House
Bill three a to pass as amended on House
Bill 340 with Amendment 2025 29h is
there a second representative Harley bu
is seconds we're now on discussion of
the bill as amended
is there I don't need to go through my
speech again so uh is there a discussion
on the bill as
amended uh hearing none the clerk will
call the role the motion is ought to
340 okay chairman Barry chair votes
yes representative Pomo Ryan yes
representative Burnham yes
representative warry yes representative
wood yes representative Harvey bolia yes
representative C yes representative
goovi yes representative toner yes
representative major
yes representative Lane no
representative Ward
no representative Gilmore no
representative
Mirad no representative Grill no
Representative wilham no representative
no so it's 10 to8 okay and with that the
motion of ought to pass comes out 10 to8
I assume there will be a minority report
represent L who will be responsible for
the Minority
Report representative
Mirad and I uh I assume your motion
would be itl I assume the motion on that
will be itl for the Minority Report okay
trusting but
verifying all right and I think that's
all of our business today um I'll close
the executive session on House Bill 340
uh can housekeeping notes I have all of
the testimony that was handed in today
in front of me so if any member would
like any of the written testimony that
was submitted I have it in front of me
before I package it up uh and give it
give it over to the clerk so with that
um go ahead and plan for next Tuesday um
and I'll meet very quickly
with uh representative Lane and Mirad to
discuss scheduling for next week but as
I said earlier I I do have to go um so